Donald Trump yesterday had a press availability,
I guess we would call it at the white house.
This was before Iran attacked two U S military
bases in Iraq. And it was a strange sort of
gong show, combination of rambling, confusing
and dishonest. And it's becoming increasingly
embarrassing to be a Trump supporter now to,
to normal people. That is, I think within
their, you know, cult Trump supporters, uh,
during, within the world of the cult Trump
supporter. They're probably still pretty outwardly
happy with their choice, at least as far as
they're willing to admit. But when you see
Donald Trump behave in this way, make no sense.
Tell lies, inaccuracies look confused and
disheveled.
This has to be embarrassing for a Trump supporter,
right? Or are they so cognitively dissonant
that they even see this and think, wow, that's
who I'm voting for for reelection. Let's look
at some clips. Donald Trump was first asked,
what did you know about Sola Moni when you
decided to assassinate him? And this is an
important question because we've since learned
since the assassination, we've learned that
Donald Trump essentially knew nothing about,
uh, Kaseem Sola Mani, but he was reportedly
talked into the assassination by some of the
people around him, even though it had originally
been presented by the Pentagon as the crazy
option that they were offering, not expecting
that he would take it. And Donald Trump confirms
it. In this first clip, he really knew nothing
about Kaseem Solemani Eric,
about what evidence you had the Kasam Salomone
was planning attacks against American targets.
What can you tell us about what you knew prior
to ordering the attack? Well, number one,
I knew the past. His past was horrible. He
was a terrorist. He was so designated by president
Obama, as you know, and he wasn't even supposed
to be outside of his own country. He was so
right there. But that's in a way the least
of it. We had an attack very recently that
he was in charge of where we had people horribly
wounded, one dead. In fact, the number now
as of this morning, I believe is two dead,
and that was his. He was traveling with the
head of Hezbollah. They weren't there to discuss
a vacation. They weren't there to go to a
nice resort someplace in Baghdad. They were
there to discuss bad business, and we saved
a lot of lives by terminating his life. A
lot of lives of saved and they were planning
something, and you'll go in to be hearing
about it, or at least, uh, various people
in Congress are going to be hearing about
it tomorrow. Our secretary of state covered
it very well. A little while ago. I saw him,
I saw his news conference.
So this is the same razor thin justification
that they've been parroting for several days.
And you'll see later in a clip with my Palm
PEO that they've already shifted to a different
justification for the Kaseem Solemani assassination.
But we'll get to that. Donald Trump then in
the same press avail is asked about his threat
of war crimes. Donald Trump, remember on Twitter
threatening to target Iranian cultural heritage
sites. And here's what he had to say.
Also clear up mr president, whether Iranian
cultural sites wouldn't be on any future targets.
Well, as I said yesterday was very interesting.
They are allowed to kill our people. They're
allowed to Mae Mar people. They're allowed
to blow up everything that we have and there's
nothing to stop them. And we are according
to, uh, various laws, uh, supposed to be very
careful with their cultural heritage. And
you know what, if that's what the law is,
I like to obey the law, but think of it, they
kill our people. They blow up our people that
we have to be very gentle with their cultural
institutions. But I'm okay with it. It's okay
with me.
Oh, these laws, they say we have to be so
careful. We have to be gentle. But importantly,
notice that Donald Trump is now backtracking,
saying, okay, we will obey the law. I guess
the war crimes have been canceled by Donald
Trump. Good thing. Yesterday I told you that
the Pentagon immediately said, yeah, Trump's
suggesting we target Arabian cultural sites.
We wouldn't do that. The Pentagon immediately
saying, that's not something that they would
do. Then it got really weird as if what we've
seen so far isn't weird enough. Donald Trump
was asked about the Greek population in the
United States. Check out what he had to say.
Say it with Greece. So, uh, Greece and I and
my people and we have a whole group of people
and as you see that brought a lot of great
representatives from Greece that we've been
dealing with. Uh, we have a tremendous Greek
population, over 3 million people as I understand
it. That's fantastic. I think, I know, I really
feel, I know most of them. I think I know
all of them. Come to think of it, but it's
a great population in the United States. We're
going to be meeting, we're going to be talking,
we're going to be negotiating and we're going
to be making a lot of deals.
Greece and I love that. Greece, he talks about
Greece and I, the Greek population is tremendous.
Now, a quick fact check. There are not 3 million
Greek people in the United States. The number
is less than half that 1.4 million Americans
of Greek descent. Now that can be sort of
vague, only about 320,000 people in the U
S above age five speak Greek at home as of
a few years ago. But never let the facts get
in the way of a good hyperbolic ramble. And
then Donald Trump for good measure repeats
the complete and total lie that he was strongly
against the Iraq war. Remember, he was not
strongly against the Iraq war. Uh, but here
is Donald Trump repeating this yet again.
Let's see. We don't want to be there forever.
We want to be able to get out. I didn't want
to be there the first place to be honest.
And everybody knows that now. That was what
I was a civilian. I said it, but we were there
and they made a decision. And uh, I disagreed
with that decision very strongly. But we're
there now. We've done a great job. We've gotten
rid of the caliphate. 100% of the caliphate
has gone.
Now here is Donald Trump saying that he was
in favor of the Iraq war on the Howard stern
show in 2002 I've played this clip for you
before and it is particularly relevant here.
Really don't know the enemy. You know they're
skulking around somewhere and you just feel
like you're a sitting duck. But we have an
idea that the enemy is in. A lot of times
the politicians don't want to tell you that.
Are you for invading Iraq? Yeah, I guess so.
Uh, you know, I wish it was, I, I wished the
first time it was done correctly. Right, but
you still against rebuilding the world trade
center. I'm not against rebuilding
very clearly. Not a guy who was against the
Iraq war. So it's exhausting to keep up with
it all. It never makes any sense. It's a mess.
It's a worldwide laughing stock. And meanwhile,
Donald Trump always seems to be a few talking
points behind on these things because now
Donald Trump's own secretary of state, Mike
Pompeo has come up with a new justification
for assassinating Kaseem Solemani. That's
actually even more incoherent than the one
Trump gave. Remember the initial justification
for the assassination of the Iranian Koons
leader that started this entire thing, including
two U S military bases being bombed last night
was a justification based on the imminence
of an attack plan by Kaseem Solemani, uh,
based on what he was doing now and, um, Donald
Trump parroted that during his press avail.
But then here is Mike Palm PEO talking about,
Oh no, the justification is attacks that took
place sometimes in the past, which is a completely
different explanation.
Uh, the opportunity that we thought might
present itself at some point. Uh, and we could
see clearly that, uh, not only had Soleimani
done all of the things that we have recounted,
right? Hundreds of thousands of massacre in
Syria, uh, enormous destruction of countries
like Lebanon and Iraq where they've denied
them sovereignty and the ratings have really
denied people in those two countries. What
it is they want, right? Sovereignty, independence
and freedom is, this is all Solomanis handiwork.
And then we'd watch to see what's continuing
the terror campaign in the region. Uh, we
know what happened, uh, at the end of last
year in December. Ultimately leading to the
death of an American,
so a shift from it was an imminent threat,
which has been widely debunked because there
was no evidence of presented with that too.
This was really more punishment for things
that were done in the past. The reason they
can't get their stories straight is because
none of the stories make sense and this was
all framed up as an attempt by Donald Trump
to distract from impeachment and to as he
sees it, help him in his reelection campaign
in an election that is now just about 10 and
a half months away. This is going to continue
getting worse unless an adult can get into
the room and make sure that it doesn't, it's
not clear that that's going to happen. We'll
keep following it and by the time you listen
to or watch this clip from may have bombed
Iran, we, we, we just cannot predict what
is
going to happen next.